while most of us are still sleeping the
wheels here are well and truly turning
royal mail staff sifting sorting and
stuffing thousands of bags of our post
while many of these workers have been
here for decades there is an unease an
acknowledgment that even with a good job
the coming months will be tough i've got
two daughters
and uh instead of looking at
i go to like basic buyers you know where
you can get things that are running out
but
you could just get them a little bit
cheaper so i'll be doing that and just
cutting things down as i can we're just
like trying to do the best we can with
what we earn really
spread it that little bit further
it's hard it's really really hard are
you worried about the winter yeah i am
the reason according to the union at
least is that wages just aren't keeping
up workers here have balloted to strike
over it rejecting a 5.5 pay rise and
their fears are widespread just look
nationwide wages when compared with
inflation have fallen by the largest
amount on record
but inflation worries businesses too
this one says it's already losing money
and desperately needs to adapt securing
a future for everyone here if we were to
do an inflation repair eyes without
making the changes required we wouldn't
be able to make a profit we're not
making a profit we can't make the
investment we need in the network we're
not going to do that we're going to
strive to deliver job security for our
employees
there is a cruel contrast in the economy
at the moment on the one hand
unemployment's at record lows and that's
good news but on the other inflation is
so high sometimes being in a job isn't
always enough
the problem is that theoretically
raising wages could make inflation worse
and then if a recession comes as is
forecast workers could also lose their
bargaining power
recession is the dark cloud that could
make everything worse in birmingham
business looked busy enough but if
workers can't afford to spend and
companies suffer jobs could well be at
risk businesses might cut back in other
ways and they might do that by
decreasing the size of their workforce
so there's a risk that the level of
vacancies which is currently really high
near record highs could fall back and in
the slightly longer term we could see
unemployment start to rise too
strikes over pay are being touted from
teachers to nurses to lawyers from the
railways to the ferries to the tubes
many feel things are already bad enough
helen and smith sky news